because I know you and Betsy have a
little bit of difference between policy
and politics
yes how do you and she determine the
distinction between those those areas
right well maybe I should walk into why
we even got into policy and then how we
even got slightly into politics it's not
it really wasn't by choice we start off
by saying we want to work on
environmental issues and as we started
studying environmental issues we
realized that policy with such a key
part of it whether it's land
conservation or energy use or
agriculture or food policy as what
drives at all and then as you start
becoming a student of policy you realize
that there's politics that's really
behind the policy that's how policy
against written it gets changed by the
politics and so we sort of morphed
perhaps me more so than betsy morphed
into the politics side said look if we
really want to make a difference we
probably need to figure out the politics
and so for a couple years we were fairly
engaged in the politics thinking that it
would really make a difference and we
are less engaged at this point in time
because yes it does make a difference
but we've realized that that's not an
area that we want to spend that much
time on you have to really dedicate
yourself to the politics side and and
that's not who we are I think we are
more want to get our hands dirty Betsy
literally in the ground in me in working
with companies or with small
organizations and we do support policy
and organizations large environmental
organizations that are pushing the
policy of course it's key but I think we
have backed off a little bit than last
couple years